hello there I'm gav I'm Dan we're the
slo-mo guys this video is sponsored by
Amazon shopping app
you've just joined us having a cheeky
game of pool
as you do you know what's a bit weird
but there's no one else playing pool
though I was just about to say that I
had thought that actually what's going
on I don't understand it your break I
think okay excellent yeah I have got a
mean break though so be prepared for a
lot of balls to go in
okay I put two one in one went off yeah
the one that went in was actually the
cue ball but
so
there we go well not bad but still I've
noticed there's still a lot of balls
here I think we can do better than that
I think so too yeah
you know actually there's a thing in
pool where if you hit the cue ball into
another ball that you're hitting into
another ball that you're hitting yeah
and that goes in
it's called a cannon
I see where you're going with it yeah
pop this in a cannon yeah yeah all right
far oh it's a mission isn't it
all right I've spotted it
here she is
well beaut ah
I'll be honest I imagined it bigger well
I mean it's got to fire a billiard ball
right so it can be so big it's the
perfect size yeah I mean it fits real
nice and snug down there oh yeah that is
snug almost dropped here
and we are a mere well how far away are
we uh pool table's probably 350 meters
maybe 400 I reckon
this thing will get it will get there
but how good is your aim gonna be well
we've got three things on the side we've
got consistency in the balls consistency
in the amount of powder and the angle is
going to be the same every time as well
okay hone it in yeah all right I've got
a 25 grams of powder which is just over
half a load basically the maximum is
like 55 grams okay I'm gonna pour that
in I mean we're very far away from the
edge of this cliff and there's basically
nothing over the cliff but I would like
to see where it lands so we can hone in
our aim yeah so
I'm going to lock it in place and I'll
find out the angle so we can replicate
it again load the fuse in so it's
touching the powder like so I've got
about 15 inches of fuse which give me
plenty of time to get out of there okay
now the last step is to put the ball in
so no one stand in front of the cannon
for obvious reasons yep I'm gonna load
the ball okay okay we got both cameras
connected to the same trigger line
which is wrapped around the side away
from this we have the 4K position behind
running at a thousand frames a second
and because that isn't going to do much
in terms of the detail around the shock
wave potentially we're using the TMX
7510 on a much closer angle 80 000
frames a second I'll meet you around
there excellent good luck
I'm sure I'll be fine loading
use let fuse is lit
is my trigger button down here
protected by all this
that was beefy wasn't it hence that was
only half a load oh like this is going
to be so hard to find the ball like I
said it's a white they were in a white
Quarry it's a white ball and I didn't
see where it went
powder's lit uh you can there's a
definite indicator when it's lit isn't
there take a split second look at the
gas gunk coming out the front
and all of that is coming around the
ball yeah we saw how snug the ball was
yeah and you saw how there it was look
at that look at the flame coming out
like sideways you can actually see it
blowing Flames into the back of the ball
there it's a really like the explosions
just trying to get out of there yeah and
then as soon as the ball's gone then it
is allowed more to come out so that
means as soon as the gas starts coming
around the ball it's no longer
accelerating that's why they use a
muzzle velocity rather than
wow
see the shock wave there that was it's
amazing there's like different layers to
it there's like look at it there's like
three layers to it yeah and it's good
and it's doming out it's coming all
around move up some dust there's the
ball I see it oh yeah it's hidden
slightly in the oh look you can see if
you look at the ball there's a you can
see we're waiting on it yeah that's
where the gas has not been able to get
past it it's charred one hemisphere yeah
so you've got a half like charred ball
wow it's like a freaking laser beam
that's amazing so I'm putting full 50
gram loading
happy with this angle aren't we yep
who's lit
this is exciting
the sound Reverb right there and back
and there we go did you see the ball I
didn't see it I didn't see it
did you went anywhere near the table
[Music]
foreign
yeah that's the first shock wave it's
very light in comparison look at all of
the unburned propellant you can see it
whoa coming out good look at that wow
is it can you just stop it
there look at that there's a sunlight
reflection on the ball
oh like we fired a Red Bull for this one
just because we wanted to find it look
at all this extra stuff behind it as
well and look how much it kicks up oh
wow that was like a bloody it was
revolver yeah again as soon as the the
balls come out then the recall happens
oh
it's the same as the other one except it
doesn't drop it's just spinning away
it's it's like spinning to the right do
you see that I feel like it's not like a
solid archery I tell you what I don't I
don't say this too often we're watching
this too slow I'm gonna speed this up
really look at it what
what it's like it's like pelayed into
the sky
this might be a bit difficult
yeah yeah I came into this with some
confidence and after having fired it you
know and seeing how far away the pool
table is I have
no confidence uh why don't we just bring
the pool table over here
that is a lot closer all right look okay
I feel like I feel like instead of doing
the the longest yeah distance break
we'll just do the most powerful break
yeah we determined in some of the other
shots the smoke is about four lengths of
the cannon until the ball emerges so by
putting them here give us a little
breathing room for the smoke so we
actually should see the ball hit the
ball the 4K is in charge of the wide for
the shot hidden behind this truck and in
the truck is the TMX on a pretty high
angle looking down at the balls my
prediction
so this little puny table is going to
stay here and the ball's just going to
go like that oh no I don't think it'll
stay here I think it'll be annihilated
but I think it will be enough just to
deflect the ball above these okay my
prediction yeah
top half of the ball okay the cue ball
will get shattered and the pieces will
go all up like this and the rest of
these balls are just going to go
everywhere for the sake of the footage I
hope you're right instead of me me too
I'm a little bit nervous but not because
it's unsafe because we're going to be
well clear I've done all the precautions
but mainly because I want it to work I
want it to work too Sun's getting pretty
low there it's true right
um pull in
Tamp down
lighting the fuse
fuse is lit
I heard one Bang
did we miss sounded like a mess
it's a Miss wow oh
oh look at that
it must have got the glanciest of
glancing blows because it hasn't moved
the table an inch and the balls have
only been Disturbed that much your
prediction you nailed it unfortunately I
know
oh
It's On Target that is that's a pretty
tragic effect on target you know what I
didn't think what we'd hit the table and
be able to just reuse it straight away
oh we're getting some Gump coming in
here oh is this like the propellant yeah
yeah looks like comets for ants
a lot in there this is all the stuff
that's snuck around the seal of the ball
might be also because the ball was level
remember I didn't tilt it at all it was
perfectly left oh wow oh it's got the
same pack in it so it's come out and
tipped forward slightly yeah wow so it's
knocked the what's happened is it's
knocked the front of the table and now
it's spinning because it's at the table
you imagine all the other balls just
like
it's just like imagine all these balls
have just flawed it into like hyperdrive
it looks like they're just doing a
wheelie they're booking it through space
they simultaneously lifted there that
lifted the whole table over here
[Music]
bang off the end cushion well that's one
way to do it it's not a regulation pool
table anymore unfortunately but I think
we could have a good game we just got to
be careful with this end
is the regulation Cannon cleaner
yeah
does a very good job though
and this is a regulation camon wiper
or a paint roller it's a paint roller
okay yep okay now we're ready for
another shot let's do it
use that
I heard one bang again
didn't sound that different
huh
oh dear oh
oh that's a definite hit look at it
oh there's a ball that's just
is that a yellow ball there and a cue
ball I think I've shattered the front
ball and the cue ball
oh oh
I got two pockets no oh that's
unbelievable
with a cannon
amazing
that's unbelievable
you know what B
I've peaked at Paul you can't get better
you can't get better than that you'll be
worried about losing a ball off the end
of this you've still got it in the
pocket it's not even a song look at it
it's still gone in
oh
oh wow
I can't wait to see the footage of that
I cannot wait
look at how far some of the balls man
the Red Bull's over there so we've got
the same effect with the propellant
coming first yeah this looks identical
to the previous shot let's see if it was
a top clip or a oh it's got to be a
topic I'll tell you a little secret
though I aimed it slightly down oh so
is this gonna be clean oh
would be better I collapsed the monitor
because any excitement look at that
wow this is nothing of it just powdered
the first ball immediately
look you can see the hemisphere of the
ball as well it's pretty much dead on
that it must have gone into thousands of
pieces yeah thousands
it looks like an egg because of the the
yolky color
yeah oh yeah you got the white mixing
with the yolk yeah
couldn't be cleaner I was if anything
millimeters off
it's the cube on the front ball and the
rest of them yeah the rest of them just
look completely I'll tell you what you
should do we should get just a little
Phantom shot of you just going
hard cut between I love it I love it
yeah there you go just just go back to
the intro and be like remember when I
said yeah I've got a free movie yeah
that's the end of the video just forget
about the cannon completely
oh those pieces went miles I did see
something land on the like dust 60
meters away what's this here oh that's
the underneath of the table yeah
slightly higher it's hit the bottom of
the table it's just
oh come on
your balls are on the Move look
iron off the cushion
oh
oh perfect you triggered that part it's
like you knew the very beginning is the
cannon and the very end of the recording
is the last ball game yeah so we said
we'd be really careful about
not rolling off the that end of the
table and we didn't no we didn't yeah
take
um
thank you um you're up need some chalk
for this kind of deal I assume you are
choosing Stripes yeah yeah and we're
just going to ignore the eight balls
scattered throughout the Quarry yeah
yeah I don't know what to win don't know
why you need the queue here I've
obviously got this well you know Iron up
that four just in case you miss
never mind all day it's all over a
deserved win thank you based on that
break
big old thanks to Amazon shopping app
for sponsoring this video couldn't have
done this level of Destruction without
them we use the Amazon shopping app to
purchase some of the props used in this
video such as the pool table and the
balls oh and that one one of the many
benefits of the Amazon shopping app is
Live 24 7 chat support and if you're
anything like me after you've started a
support chat you'll forget immediately
that you've started it so thankfully it
will remain open for 24 hours you can
also see exactly what you're purchasing
with full 360 degree product views it
lets you see items from every angle
viewing your room make sure it fits by
using your phone's camera and VR so you
can see it where it's going to be we'll
use it in the Quarry
will it fit use it in your room or the
Quarry there is real-time delivery
tracking so you can see exactly where
your package is how many stops away is
that's great for me I just always get
really excited no matter what it is even
if it's just the smallest thing I'm
always like a parcel I still get that
little hit like a bag of zip ties or
something literally
I'm like tracking it is it here yet you
can download the Amazon shopping app
today using the link in the description
big thanks to Amazon shopping app for
sponsoring this video I'm gonna need
another table and some more balls as
well we might yeah I think this one's
fine
like I say I've definitely played them
worse okay hopefully you enjoyed that
video make sure you subscribe if you
like slow-mo and we'll see you next time
rack them up again yeah